- aaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaal
dans le nord de l'Alberta,
ltltlten Sloan prend sa destinée
en main.
Chaque séance d'entraînement
le rapproche de son but :
devenir l'homme le plus fort
Colten Sloan se décrit comme
pieds trois pouces et 330 lb.
Sa vie est dictée pour
sa passion pour le sport et
son régime spartiate. Chaque
jour, il doit avaler au iriririr
sa condition physique et
continuer ses expl...
Depuis octobre, il est
considéré comme le premier homme
fort professionnel autochtone
de l'histoire canadienne.
Il se réjouit que ces réf
Le parcours de Colten Sloan a
toujours été parsemé dûûûches.
Obtenir ce titre est une raison
Colten Sloan doit son salut
à ce sport. Sa passion lui
permet de faire le deuil de
décédée du cancer ce printemps.
L'athlète trouve réconfort
dans lntntnte. Il souhaite
maintenant transmettre
ce message aux autres.
P : : : : : : : : : : : : : :Én
P P P P P P P P P P P P P P P e
fort : les États-Unis à la finda
de se qualifier pour une place
au Championnat du mond